now it's time for the final thought
political analysts are like sports
commentators they only focus on the
major leagues and they keep showing up
to work no matter how many times their
predictions turn out to be wrong now
these two character traits are related
most Talking Heads have never passed out
pom cards to commuters at a train
station or sat through a summer of
spaghetti dinners at the VFW hall
instead they attend cocktail parties
with their fellow political media and
donor class elite and that's all well
and good I like cocktail parties they've
read all of the philosophic and social
scientific literature they've crunched
the numbers and they devour every myopic
op EDL who have even less perspective on
the voting populace than they themselves
now those data points are not without
value but all politics is particular
politics comprises particular goals
effected through particular people
caused by particular issues there is a
significant a substantial group of
voters that cannot be reached by opinion
polls Richard Nixon called them the
silent majority george w bush called
them Values Voters and Hillary Clinton
called them deplorable 'he's far-distant
elites cannot pin them down and yet they
often decide American elections god
bless america
I'm Michael Knowles is the Michael Nolt
show come back tomorrow we'll do it all
again
[Music]
[Music]